we have new economic numbers they're
pretty good
new weekly jobless claims have again hit
a new pandemic era
low the department of labor once a week
releases these numbers they released
them this morning
initial jobless claims for the week
ending april
10th meaning last week came in at
576 000 new claims
this is both lower than the 700
000 number that was expected and also
the lowest in the era of the pandemic
continuing claims uh for the week ending
april 3rd
3.7 million the uh basically right on
track with what was
expected and these are numbers that are
likely to continue improving
if we can keep vaccinating quickly we've
talked about how
in some sense the unemployment numbers
are
inversely correlated to vaccination of
course there's a whole bunch of other
factors including local hot spots and
state-by-state guidelines what's going
on in texas
is different than what's going on in the
state of washington
as as two examples but if you look at
the vaccination
dose numbers those numbers continue to
increase we're now
up to 3.3 million doses per day
in another 40 days things could be
looking quite
good it's quite plausible that by
memorial day you will see more states
drop
mask mandates i'm not advocating for or
against it i'm sort of talking about the
the perspective that i think more and
more governors are taking here
but short of of debating that
for me the lesson here there's probably
a few lessons but the best lesson here
is
the best economic policy the best way to
protect and shield
and recover the economy during a
pandemic
has always been to just deal with the
virus and what i mean by that is
early on in march debates about
flights and debates about freedom and
debates about
masks and closures quarantines and the
constitutionality of lockdowns and all
of that stuff
there has always been one path
which is the most uh the the more
quickly
you deal with the virus regardless of
the debates around freedom and
constitutionality and whatever
dealing with the virus most quickly
will help the economy and we have
examples of it new zealand did an
incredible job dealing with the virus
they didn't need long debates over
whether to open or close or max or not
they just they did it they dealt with it
and then they had long periods of
normality where much of the rest of the
world
was very far from normality israel in
terms of vaccination israel was
able to strike a deal early with pfizer
uh being a country of only nine million
people to get enough doses for everybody
uh in exchange for sharing data with
pfizer
uh businesses are open in israel
passover was almost completely normal in
israel
a couple of weeks ago the entire time
the united states wasted time with
conversations that were being forced
upon us
by the right by the trumpists by the
anti-massacres by whoever else
and all along the best medical policy
was the best economic policy that's what
we learned and it is increasingly
borne out in the data that we get had we
figured out testing earlier instead of
trump saying
we don't need this slow down testing 15
cases will go to zero if we just figured
out testing and were able
to contain it we would have had a
problem of course we would have had a
problem in a country of 330 million
people
but it wouldn't have gotten as bad as it
did the economy would have gotten better
more quickly
had we had competent leadership early
the economy would have done better
all along other good indicators uh
economically by the way retail sales
up uh about nine percent higher in march
that is uh significant a lot of it is
coming from bars and restaurants
and other uh business areas um
and then the result of all of this is
the stock market popping today
all-time highs you're not seeing joe
biden tweet endlessly about it
but the dow jones industrial average was
up more than 200 points
as of when i looked at it half an hour
ago um
hit an all-time high the s p 500 hitting
an intraday
record like forever the the forever
record was hit today
uh nasdaq up one percent of course the
economy is not the stock market
but the point is all of it together
confirms
that the better we do against the virus
that's the economic policy
it's not the debate between public
health policy
and economic policy it's all the same
the economy does better when we better
deal with the virus
we better deal with the virus when we
understand
that we don't need to think about the
virus as separate and distinct from the
economy
because it all goes hand in hand we'll
hope for continued
improvement in the numbers my belief is
and again i always make very clear i'm
not
coming up with this stuff on my own i'm
looking at the public health experts
because they are the experts
it seems as though 40 days from now
numbers will look significantly better
and hopefully as a result economic
numbers will as well
a for a fox news debate between geraldo
rivera
and radical right-wing former secret
service agent
dan bongino exploded last night
into screaming and insults and you know
in this segment
i don't actually care to talk about the
substance of what geraldo and dan
bongino are talking about
what i want to talk about is how
worthless this type of media is and it
actually relates to this show in a way
as well and something we've been doing
or not doing maybe better said
we're gonna look at a sec segment on fox
news that is now down to the level of
those sort of like
internet blood sports type channels if
you haven't seen them
good you're missing nothing but the way
that these internet blood sports
channels work
are there live streams where you might
have two people plus a host
or or like a panel of four sometimes
it's it's ten people
just screaming at each other sometimes
these things go
three four five hours no one learns
anything
i'm often invited to participate in them
and i never do because i don't want to
waste my time
let's look at this segment the general
topic is the unrest
in minnesota surrounding the police
shooting of 20 year old dante wright
the police officer has been charged with
second-degree manslaughter we will be
talking about the charge
on today's bonus show of course dan
bongino in this segment is not being
particularly sympathetic to the victim
and their family
and it just completely explodes and
devolves into
screaming and insults take a look at
this you tell that to the black families
that see their sons being killed that's
all you twice the rape
you've got nothing else buddy you've got
nothing else that's a fact
you've got nothing else all you want to
do is see the country
you just want to see the country burn
that's it
you wouldn't tell me that to my face
we'll leave it there
coming up the left continue now if your
instinct is like mine
at least initially you feel like okay it
sort of seems like geraldo
is more on the right side here than dan
bongino i hear geraldo talking about the
relative rate of police shootings
against black men versus
white men okay maybe like the broader uh
uh maybe in some sense geraldo is is
making more sense here
the broader analysis is that this is
trash
this is this is garbage you know those
uh
russian nested dolls they're called
matryoshka dolls you open one
and there's another slightly smaller
doll inside and then you open that one
and it you know
all the way down that's what this is
of nonsense and what i mean by that is
you start with the big picture right the
biggest doll
fox news is a propaganda network with a
right-wing slant they deliberately blur
the lines
between news and opinion and they use
that blurring to feed
ignorant right-wingers exactly what they
want while running interference and
carrying water for republican
politicians and administrations that's
fox big picture
okay you open that up you look at an
individual show
the individual shows are just a disaster
you've got
gutfeld the supposed comedy show it's
not funny
you have janine pirro on the weekends
when she's not drunk
she's making no sense anyway uh you've
got you know hannity tucker carlson they
have completely bamboozled their
audiences
into thinking that they report news when
they get sued their lawyers will quickly
say this is entertainment this is
entertainment but the viewers don't
realize that
you have hannity who's friends with
trump and repeats trump's propaganda and
people watch it and they don't realize
this is just trump's friend
feeding me nonsense you have tucker
carlson who's doing subtle white
nationalist talking points we talked
about that earlier this week
you open up the individual show box
and then you get to a specific episode
about
what's going on in minneapolis where the
entire framing is always to defer
and default to the position of police
you open
that up and you get to this single
segment with geraldo and dan bongino
it's a debate supposedly to give us two
opinions
maybe haraldo's opinion is a better one
than bongino
but it's all sensationalist trash it's
just
blood sports from which we learn nothing
and this is partially why i've done less
and less of the debate the right stuff
with bad faith
people all the time we used to bring on
just these morons bad faith right
wingers
and i would argue with them and it was
interesting sort of like for shock
value and entertainment value and they
did pretty well
but we didn't really learn anything and
no one learns
anything from this it's just garbage
it's not worth the electricity
and the bandwidth required to produce it
and to watch it
one more segment from this just to show
you how how
completely vapid it is statistics but he
doesn't know any of that
um but secondly uh
so my hope is and i've i've said this
before
i hope that people watch some
shows like mine not trying to put myself
out of business
but my shows if you think of a food
pyramid
where you put the junk food at the top i
hope that people are building
their knowledge of the world and of
important issues first by
understanding how to think epistemology
critical thinking media literacy on top
of that
you build your knowledge of history
and uh geopolitics
and political philosophy by reading
books
on top of that you read reporting
ideally original reporting and then you
pick some commentary and opinion
like my show at the top of the pyramid
for flavor right
if you're only watching fox news and
many people are
only watching fox news that's where they
get everything they get their world view
they get their phil you know everything
comes from from
fox news um if that's how you learn and
you get informed
it's a disaster and we will never solve
the problems that we have
in this country so uh you know i don't
even care to adjudicate geraldo versus
dan bongino here
this is just like the logical end point
of as we
you know unpacked those russian dolls
when you start with what fox news is
and you go to what shows are on fox news
and then you look at
the hosts that fox news selects and then
you go down to the segment level
you get a segment that is of i would
it's not even zero value i would argue
it's of negative value if
that's how you inform yourself about the
issue in minneapolis
you end up less informed and less able
to really understand what's going on
if this is what counts as news for you
let me know what you think am i being
too harsh
find me on twitter deepakman
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing
you get access to the world famous bonus
show every single day
just for members as well as commercial
free audio and video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership
very very quickly at joinpacman.com
that's
join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by all means use the coupon code
better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
the david pakman show is mostly funded
by viewers and listeners
like you we don't have a money tree we
don't have big corporate
sponsors lavishing us with gifts and uh
cash uh we mostly depend on people who
just grab a membership at joinpacman.com
we do an extra show
every day for those members you can sign
up
using the coupon code better21 if you
like
if you prefer patreon you can also sign
up at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow i would encourage you to
join the discussion on the david pakman
show
subreddit we are just so close so close
to 30
000 of our viewers and listeners being
subscribed to the subreddit
find it at davidpakman.com reddit some
interesting posts from this morning
one article uh lets us know
that creationism can be taught as
science
in arkansas classrooms according to what
lawmakers there are saying
and indeed it is horrifying house bill
1701
has passed the house in arkansas
which will allow the teaching of
creationism
as science for kindergarten
through twelfth grade kindergarten
through twelfth grade not in religious
studies
mind you as science it now goes to the
senate
i don't know if it will pass the senate
but this is
very very ugly we talk about education
on the program quite a bit and i point
out that while it would be great to deal
with
some elements of the educational
problems federally
in the united states much of education
is decided at the state level by state
boards of education
state boards of education and
this is one such example it's absolutely
horrible
we will see what the senate does state
senate in arkansas but
at least the state house saying yeah
creationism
that belongs in science class which is a
horrifying horrifying situation another
post
on the subreddit about the latest police
shooting
says in the army there's no such thing
as an accidental discharge there are
only
negligent discharges saying the army is
very lenient when it comes to mistakes
made in the heat of the moment
but if a soldier failed to do his or her
duty by ensuring they employed the
correct weapon
and that negligence resulted in a death
the soldier would be facing
non-judicial punishment as a bare
minimum but likely a court
martial that soldier supervisor would
also be held accountable
why aren't cops held to the same
standard
well understand as has pointed out in
the thread
that there are ways in which the
military
actually has higher standards than
domestic us-based
police forces uh and this often relates
to
uh use of force but yeah as i said um
earlier this week i believe from the
video
that the officer in brooklyn center
minnesota
did not intend to shoot the victim
but that doesn't make it an accident
where we say
let's just walk away from this thing it
was an accident
it's it's negligence when as an officer
you know you as a police officer you
don't need to know much about for
example
uh astrophysics but you need you do need
to know whether you've got the taser or
the gun
that seems like a fundamental
fundamental part of policing uh she has
been charged now with second-degree
manslaughter and we'll talk about that
more on the bonus show
and see uh what what that is likely
going to look like
one other thing a bread for all user
bread for all
posted does david deepak
pakman the first of the david pakman
show
on youtube and elsewhere actually have a
middle name
i do not i do not and what distinguishes
me
from the other david pakman the venture
capitalist who we've had on the show
is uh he has a middle name he has a
middle name and i do not but no i have
no middle name and uh i
want to to be publicly fully known that
that is the case okay join the
discussion whether it's about
police shootings or my middle name it's
all valid
on the subreddit which you can find at
davidpakman.com
slash r-e-d-d-i-t
this is super interesting and very much
worth
spending some time on today there is a
guy named alex berenson
alex berenson is not a doctor
but has been front and center throughout
the pandemic
making tons of claims about the virus
about the pandemic itself about
containment guidelines
about masks vaccination the spread of
the virus
he has been wrong on essentially
everything
there is a very good article you can
read about him
in the atlantic called the pandemic's
wrongest man
just some of his greatest hits include
blaming vaccines
for more coronavirus cases suppressing
the immune system
saying israel suffered from being early
to vaccinate
that the vaccine side effects are worse
than covet itself for anybody
other than seniors i could go on and on
i mean he's just been wrong about
everything i can't think of anybody
who's been this wrong
maybe trump right but but it just
weaponized
uh wrongness is what i would call it
he is also a big anti-cannabis guy
very much against marijuana he's even
written books about
how bad marijuana is the books are trash
they're filled with anecdotes and
cherry-picked
so-called data so yesterday alex
berenson goes on tucker carlson i guess
tucker has a new daytime show it's a
second show called
tucker carlson today you can distinguish
the shows because on his nighttime
show tucker is wearing a tie on his
daytime show
tucker is not wearing a tie i watched
a two-minute clip tucker and alex
berenson
talking about cannabis i was actually
stunned at how much
incorrect information is squeezed
into such a short period of time there
must be some record here for falsehoods
per minute
let's just jump right into it and and
start seeing if we can understand what's
going on
community will acknowledge that cannabis
can cause you know a fair number of
people especially if you use heavily
to have kind of short-term psychotic
reactions right a bad trip but they're
peaceful though because marijuana makes
you
peaceful yeah it's the mahatma gandhi
that's right
that's right that's why that's why
violence has gone down so much in the
united states the last five years
okay so you heard berenson there
sarcastically say
you know if marijuana made people mellow
and docile
violent crime has gone down the last
five years how implying violent crime
is actually up over the last five years
now there is a reason he says in the
last five years
because crime in the united states big
picture has been on the decline for a
really
long time if you look at fbi data for
violent crimes per hundred thousand
people
violent victimizations per thousand
people age 12 or over
property crimes per 100 000 people
property victimizations per thousand
households they have
all been down down down over the last 28
years or longer
now it is true that with some indicators
the decline
sort of slowed down maybe even went
up and then back down over the last five
to seven years
it's been a less steady trend alex
berenson
apparently wants you to think that
because of marijuana law
crime is now going up because marijuana
does not actually make people docile it
makes people
violent every aspect of this claim is
wrong
first there's no evidence that marijuana
makes people violent
second we started seeing
decriminalization of cannabis
in 1973 medical cannabis legalization in
1996
recreational cannabis legalization in
2012 that's already nine
years ago so even the timeline he
implies a causality for which there's no
evidence
and he also points to a timeline that
doesn't actually correlate
with cannabis law uh violent crime has
been declining
the up and down period doesn't correlate
with cannabis uh
law changes it's just vapid let's watch
a little bit more of this so you think
that there is
i mean i'm just being completely honest
i grew up in southern california i spoke
marijuana as a child
everyone i knew believed that it
mellowed you out
right so you're saying there's evidence
of the opposite oh yeah there's i mean
again
so this is there's something called
cannibal cannabinoid hyperemesis
syndrome okay what that basically means
is uncontrolled vomiting
as a result of thc yes i've seen now
cannabis is supposed to settle you
settle your stomach
you know if you're nauseated smoke some
right that's sort of one of the famous
uses of it of course
for chemotherapy that's right but it
looks like there's this paradoxical
effect if you use too much of it that
for whatever reason somehow resets the
receptors in the brain
for some people and they have this just
terrible uncontrolled vomiting that in
some cases can actually kill there's
i'm not exaggerating because you become
so dehydrated it can kill you if you're
not careful if you don't get to an
emergency room
okay now did you see what he did there
first he says
there's this thing called cannabinoid
hyperemesis syndrome where
super high intake of thc in
some people could cause uncontrolled
vomiting now that part is true that
exists and
with countless substances medications
you can have one effect at a normal dose
and the opposite effect at a
cartoonishly
high dose there's no question of that
that's not specific to thc
it's insanely rare with thc
uh but it is not exclusive uh to thc
then he says well it can kill you
if you become super dehydrated from the
vomiting and you don't go to a hospital
and deal with the dehydration
we're no longer talking about cannabis
so understand the game that he's playing
here
anything that causes you to become
dehydrated if you don't deal with the
dehydration
you could die and if you are
uncontrollably vomiting for a long time
then you should be going to the hospital
regardless of whether it's as a result
of extremely
cartoonishly high thc intake so
he mixes something that could happen
to someone who consumes an insane amount
of thc
but then he's admitting the risk isn't
actually from the cannabis it's anything
that causes uncontrollable vomiting
and subsequent dehydration it could be a
stomach bug it could be food poisoning
could be for a whole bunch of other
reasons he's sort of slick
but it doesn't take very long to see
through the nonsense
let's just watch a little bit more um um
so so paradoxically you know so in the
short term marijuana can reduce anxiety
certainly and it can get you high but
it like most anti-anxiety drugs you can
have bad rebound anxiety if you try to
quit
i mean that's true of benzodiazepines
that's a known risk okay
further cannabis has this effect on
people where it makes them paranoid some
people
some of the time okay and if you have
this predisposition or if you're sliding
into mental illness
and you start smoking a lot you may sort
of temporarily muffle
that anxiety at the cost of your
paranoid symptoms getting worse
okay so again now he's talking about
some people get
side effects that are rare and may be
counterproductive to what you're trying
to treat
you might take cannabis for anxiety and
it makes you paranoid which then makes
you more anxious yeah that's true
this is the case with ssris for
depression and anxiety
which in some people short term medium
term you take an ssri
for anxiety it might cause anxiety you
take it for depression it could make
your depression worse
this is not new it's not unique to
cannabis
so it's if you actually go through it
it's a worthless segment there is
nothing of substantive value here
and increasingly the right is holding up
alex berenson
as some kind of brilliant truth-teller
who we should listen to because
everybody else is lying to us
but alex berenson is telling us the
truth increasingly a dangerous guy
and increasingly being held up as a hero
by right-wing media we'll have more
about this on the show's instagram page
make sure you're following us there
at david pakman show and you can follow
me on instagram at david.pakman
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about them today i'm going to be
speaking with professor catherine liu
who teaches at university of california
irvine and is also
author of the new book virtue hoarders
the case against the professional
managerial class
uh it's so great to have you on today
thank you david
so there's there's certainly a narrative
i think much of my audience will be
familiar with
that is often used in some populist
circles about
elites and non-elites or an over class
and an underclass and what one of the
things your book does that's interesting
is
you're sort of focusing in on a specific
slice that's smaller than such a simple
division uh the managerial class
professional managerial class
let's start there what what is that
who's included in it etc
so the professional manager class is an
intermediary class a lot of classic
marxists think
call it the petite bourgeois because
it's located between the working class
which is the mass
of people without college degrees now
and
late capitalism in america and the
capitalists
so this class uniquely though in the
united states has become
really really important exports one of
the most important american
creations of the post-war period the
meritocracy
and it basically does the bidding of
capitalism and the capitalist by
producing
now we think of as content and
ideological content to justify
the really staggering levels of
inequality and exploitation
that keep lip capitalism going so this
class are college educated
white-collar workers who i like to say
do jobs that
don't entail physical damage to their
bodies
now they could actually damage
themselves psychologically and
intellectually which i think is actually
the case
but what they do is reproduce the
ideology of the class system
to make it seem like it's justified that
rich people are rich
and it's justified that the masses are
poor and that there are no
universal programs that would actually
create um
a more equitable society now this is to
say though in 1977 when
john and barbara erect wrote about this
class this class has taken over
left and progressive liberal organizing
spaces
so it thinks of itself as being on the
side of progress
right and virtuous and good but actually
its actions serve only to reproduce
um the interests of capitalism yeah this
is it so i
i think many in the audience may realize
that that
when you tell me is it correct to call
this a marxist perspective
yes yeah uh as a non-marxist myself i
still think that the analysis
has has a lot of very interesting things
that that are that are accurate and
you know one of the things i was
thinking of during the 20 the rise of
the tea party in 2010
was that a lot of the people that were
supporting the tea party
they were definitely never going to
benefit from much of what the tea party
was advocating for like it wasn't even
there was a chance they would benefit
they
statistically they just weren't going to
benefit what i think is interesting
about the managerial class that you're
talking about
is that they actually to some degree
could benefit from the propping up of
the actual over class that you describe
and so there's there actually seems to
be if you want to talk about rationality
it actually seems more rational to me
that they would prop that system up
whereas it made less sense with the tea
party people
but you know i think the tea party
people and populists about which i've
written in the past
are animated by a um a rage
against the economic system that's left
them
marginalized but what they uh but what
they support were free markets
but also the val traditional values
and they hated the the liberal elites
right because
the liberal elites had created the um
crisis in which they found themselves
and they're not wrong
right you know a lot of them were not um
college educated people
they were small business people or you
know um we'd say like
crap craftsmen or you know there was
like the classic joe the plumber who
turned out to be fake but
um there were these
um this population in america which i
would say
are non-college-educated people after
world war
ii were really copiously rewarded by the
redistribution
of wealth that was put into place by
both republican
and democratic administrations after
1945
but since 1972 as you know the middle
and the working classes have seen their
wages
stagnate actually go down we've seen the
social safety net
be destroyed and so a lot of the
actual economic damage that people
suffered from in the tea parties party
setting
and i would say also when trump
supporters had to do with
the imposition of this kind of
neoliberal austerity politics
and actually free markets that were
engineered by economists academics
and elites after 1972 of both parties
right
so what they wanted in the tea party was
the less government because they thought
the government had created
you know the financial crisis and
the government didn't did
participate in creating the financial
crisis but it was wall street and
financiers as you know who really
um produced this crisis in capital
destroyed a trillion dollars in american
assets like overnight
and um there was this fantasy that they
that the tea party had that it was
people borrowing on that with bad
credit who overspent and who and they
were to blame and somehow the government
the bank
and you know some banks participated in
that i
heard this line repeated to me by a very
wealthy liberal
who said you know what caused this
crisis all those people couldn't afford
the houses
and everyone wants a flat screen tv
so in fact she is actually being more
rational
although wrong because it was actually
goldman sachs morgan stanley an aig that
created the crisis
um the credit default swap created the
crisis but there's this idea that
these poor people over consuming who
had bad credit and they brought the
world economy to its knees
and so the tea party had that idea and
they were like all mad at fox news
but also msnbc cnn watching
elite liberals have that same idea so
there's actually this consensus about
how poor people
caused um the financial crisis that tea
partiers
and liberal elites shared pmc liberally
shared yeah i don't i don't know if this
is um i don't know if this this is
analog or part of or or parallel to your
analysis but to some degree what i'm
hearing you say about the tea party and
and then also some on the left is
similar to i use the term bamboozling
but there's probably a different term
that could be used that
the populist rhetoric has succeeded with
over the last
many years where it pulls in people from
both left and right
with what are typically different voting
patterns and stated
uh values that that would differ but
the rhetoric starts to sound similar on
the left and right
but then the solutions don't match up
when you actually ask people well how
would you solve this problem
but there's a similar level of
irrationality and what i think is really
insane is that the professional
managerial classes
have always prided themselves on being
rational right reasonable they're
located in the university they all went
to fancy universities
and have credentials but they are
utterly irrational right now
and i think that the um russia gate
thing
is a really good example of their
rationale and that what happened to that
but nobody's supposed to not trust msnbc
after they made that whole kerfuffle
about something that didn't really that
they had no proof for
so that's something that's in the book
too is how i showed the pmc
elites now do not abide by the high
liberal values of either due process
or reason rationed our rational argument
in the public sphere
and you know certainly on the right
people do not believe in reason
and rational argument in the public
sphere either so our the state
of our politics today has a you know it
finds ourselves in this position where
nobody wants to defend
argument argument reasonable
um people debating each other not
agreeing with each other and the pmc
liberals like to blame this on fox news
and blame this on extreme
right forces but they are policing their
own boundaries
in the same exact way and they're
demonizing their antagonists
to make them seem like they really don't
deserve to even exist or
vote when they and then they say the
republicans want to suppress the vote
but i think that there's a lot of
contempt for non-college educated
americans
not working-class americans that's
actually in the pmc itself
yeah i'm under i the part that is less
clear to me is the the russiagate piece
because
you know i to it seems to me that
certainly there were some people who
very early on
were setting expectations that were
unreasonable like you know trump's going
to be caught on video
planning something with putin you know
that that was never going to happen
trump's going to end up in prison that
was never going to happen you know you
go back to my videos from april of 2017
and and that's what i said all along
but in in great part i don't see
maybe msnbc was doing different things
than i saw i don't really watch any of
any msnbc or that type of stuff but
from the perspective of um
that this led to not only uh
more than a dozen indictments but it
actually found enough wrongdoing to
recover more money than the
investigation cost
uh it is very clear that donald trump
was a useful idiot in a number of
different ways and part of it did
overlap with right i don't know that i
see that as the same thing that you see
it as necessarily
okay well i you know that is a very
reasonable
take and i totally appreciate that um
what i think was
what i was talking about more i guess is
the energy of condemnation that
they were sure was going to lead to an
impeachment i see
and um it works only partially
but it's so different i was alive during
you're probably too young to remember
watergate when there was bipartisan
condemnation of nixon
when the work was done to bring in the
republicans and say something so
bad has happened yeah something so
illegal has happened
that we have to condemn this person and
the russiagate thing
did find wrongdoing but it didn't
actually create because
you know our politics are so polarized
now a national consensus
but i think that's an indictment of the
republican party
i think because when i see there was a
point in watergate where where the
reason there was not impeachment
was because it became clear that
nixon was going down if it went that far
because republicans
i i think that the reason it went the
way it did is an indictment on
republicans
no i absolutely agree but i also think
there's the core
and irrational poor if you like of
republican support
um popular support for trump or
right-wing popular support for trump
that is animated by hatred of the
professional managerial class
and the more you like um have these
liberal talking heads you know pumping
people up about cultural issues
ignoring actual bread and butter
economic issues or
suffering the majority of americans the
more you will have
this label of hypocrisy being thrown at
liberal elites and this idea also that
there are
worthy people to help and unworthy
people to help
that is usually a republican and
right-wing talking point
but the liberal elite pmc has actually
done this completely like
there are good poor people and there are
bad working-class people
and we're going to give all of the moral
iniquity
to the other side well and not and they
do not see their complicity
in actually bringing us to a state where
the country is so polarized and so
divided
and animated by these class antagonisms
and hatreds
that should be talked about rationally
they can't do that though because that
would mean that they were not
um saintly in some way i think the pmc
has like tried to cloak itself
in a kind of stately identity that
always has to put itself on the right
side of things
let's look at the state of california we
have an incredible homeless problem
that is in large part generated by
regulations on housing and
land use in the state the pmc here in
the state though
they rule right the democratic elites
have super majorities and everything in
every legislative branch in this state
and yet they can only put up black
lives matters signs in their yards
and they refuse to have lower income
housing built in their neighborhoods
or homeless shelters built in their
neighborhoods or even
create higher density housing so that
we're not living in suburban
enclave suburban um hell right
this this um this state
with its veneer of liberalism and its
preachiness about tolerance
has actually created this kind of
dystopia of inequality
that they don't really actually want to
solve the um
look at the san francisco school board
they stop this now but rather than
asking for funding to get schools open
in the correct way supporting teachers
and
students they wanted to rename san
francisco public schools
44 of them one of them named after
abraham lincoln
because of the racism of the past right
that just
infuriates me so much because first of
all like i
i don't like dianne feinstein i don't
think she should have a school name but
after her but if you just go after these
cosmetic things
and then you say like people who are
from the past
like lincoln were racist what the pmc
there is saying is you know everyone who
came before us
are racist we're enlightened and we're
going to create a cosmetic
um superficial veneer of tolerance and
anti-racism
ignoring all of the structural economic
inequalities that has made the san
francisco school system
majority minority right african american
latinos
and asian american working class people
use that public school system
the wealthy elites of all um they're
mostly white but missed some of them
asian some of them african americans
some of them only
latino they send their kids to private
schools and this is what has happened in
every city in the country is this kind
of
live service to public education and
this undermining of public goods
so that the um upper tier of the pmc
can enjoy privatized education
and everyone else is left with poor
quality mass education that nevertheless
has a
veneer of um tolerance that's like a
great pmc strategy for
virtue hoarding and um reproducing
economic inequality
so in the very limited time we have left
i want to get your thoughts on
how we've talked about this issue of the
the cultural fights
that you know particularly in the trump
era the right
it's not they're not even pretending to
be about policy anymore it's
it's you know dr seuss it's cancelled
culture
cetera et cetera as a strategic
uh calculation should the left
fight these cultural issues or should
they just
ignore them and focus on policy or
something else
well the left doesn't have doesn't have
much of a commitment
to um freedom of speech right now so i
think if the left fights these issues
i'm not sure what they're going to
actually be standing on because they
actually
don't want dr seuss books to be
reproduced
those books are really problematic in
many ways but also a lot of people
enjoyed those books i enjoyed those
books for my kids and
my kid and so i i feel like the culture
war aspect of um
american politics serves elites
on both sides of the party so it doesn't
i guess the reason i think it serves the
right more
is that the left has a package right now
when it comes to
infrastructure foreign policy taxation
pandemic that's absent from a lot of the
the new right so it strikes me that it
would be better for the left to focus on
that
um their policies i i'm always someone
who's for
focusing on economic material issues
okay
that is the bottom line what is who
benefits who doesn't benefit
remain focused on the economics that's
um i think always going to work much
better and actually deliver for people
not just focus on economic policies that
will create more redistribution
redistribution of wealth but really
deliver i think the vaccine
is a sign that there can be like
publicly funded health initiatives yeah
and that's it you should focus on that
you should hope we should focus on
creating
um strong infrastructure within public
health universal health care
universal quality child care all of
these bread and butter issues that
people need in their lives desperately
right now and if you can produce that
then you can produce a sense of the
collective you can produce a sense of
progressive liberal
policies that work for people yes and so
in that sense
they should not take the bait the left
should not take the bait on the cultural
issues they should absolutely deflect
and i and you know i've had my i've been
agnostic on biden but i do feel like
he's much more progressive than obama
and that his um stimulus package should
be something that is executed with the
greatest fervor
and authority and here's here's one
thing i'm going to um
end with is that i'm not playing the pm
the pmc blame game where i say oh the
pmc they're all bad
no we need good professionals we can't
have infrastructural reconstruction of
this country
without return to the professional
standards
of both like stock broking or you know
researching universities or policy
making
and think tanks that is shielded from
the market right now all of these
knowledge workers are so
driven by profit and we need to go back
to
non-market professional standards of
being
and that's i think something that we
often lose track of in the left and we
think like oh
um anybody who's a bureaucrat is bad how
are you going to spend 1.9 trillion
dollars
correctly or well without a good
functioning bureaucracy without a good
functioning government
that's why i have no patience for the
anarcho leftists
yes you and me both you and me both the
book is virtue hoarders
the case against the professional
managerial class we've been speaking
of course with the book's author
professor catherine liu so great to have
you on today
thank you david thank you so much the
david pakman show is now
on instagram at david pakman show you
can check out
behind the scenes pictures memes
shots of the studio shots of what pat
does
all day very very concerning to a lot of
people all of that and more on the david
pakman show
instagram account at david pakman show
there is a new report out
about coronavirus in vaccinated
people and unfortunately as a
combination
of some poorly written headlines as well
as people who maybe just are not
understanding the math of what's being
reported there are people
reading about this and saying oh no the
vaccines don't work
um i believe that a lot of these folks
are just misunderstanding
the math now the new report from the cdc
explains
that out of 77 million vaccinated people
in the united states it's believed that
there have been
5 800 infections 396 people
who required hospitalization and 74
people who died and then some of the
headlines
fomented what was the reaction from many
individuals
who thought oh no the vaccine isn't
100 percent effective which we knew no
vaccine is 100
effective another reaction was wow
even vaccinated you could end up
in the hospital if you get the virus and
of course we knew that
as well these are incredibly
powerful efficacious numbers of the 77
million vaccinated people
nine 0.000096 percent died and this is
pointing
to being one of the most effective
vaccination programs
once we are at full strength uh that
humanity has ever seen
uh vaccines are not 100 protection
we i don't know how much more that has
to be said the baseline would never be
this is only good if no one ever gets
sick it's an
impossible goal it's an unreasonable
goal
to see this data and to come away
thinking the vaccine
doesn't work is horrifying because this
data
is really telling us how effectively the
vaccines do
work and then to get this gets to a lot
of black and white
thinking that has been a problem during
the pandemic on masks remember
do the masks work or don't they either
they do or they don't they either work
perfectly or they don't work at all well
no it's a percentage if one person has a
mask you're reducing
uh in a physical sense with a physical
barrier the spread of the virus if two
people have a mask
well then you're reducing it even
further the vaccine
it's not 100 we understand that
uh if one person in an interaction is
vaccinated the possibility of spread
goes down because the vaccinated person
is 90
less likely to spread and 92 to 95
percent less likely to get it
so uh if they they're less likely to
give it to the unvaccinated person
they're less likely to get it from the
unvaccinated person if you have two
people
interacting who are vaccinated the
possibility of the spread is
even smaller and if someone were to get
it of the vaccinated people it would be
less serious and
if it were serious you would be less
likely to die that's
these are confidence intervals that's
how everything works
this really is some of the best news
that we could have hoped for
and it's important to know that there's
actually this these numbers may improve
over time
on the one hand it's true that of those
77 million
vaccinated people over time as
more of those individuals are out in the
world and are potentially exposed
some more of them are going to get the
virus that's true
but as more people get vaccinated the
interactions that that cohort of 77
million has
is going to increasingly be with
vaccinated people
and that's going to reduce the contagion
even further so
we're dealing with a lot of different
things right now we've got the pause on
the johnson and johnson vaccine uh
countries and the us are still figuring
out to some degree supply and
distribution
we are waiting to see because cases have
have just been trickling up although
deaths have been continuing down as we
said yesterday or the day before we're
waiting to see when will we really
see the drop in cases that israel saw
israel say somewhere between 50 and 55
percent vaccinated
were probably a month from that in the
united states some states are closer
sadly because of vaccine hesitancy some
states are further away
but the important takeaway is how
insanely effective these vaccines
are the cdc data confirms that
and and restates that and that should
really
be focus and as we talked about uh
earlier this week and we'll we're going
to look at tomorrow
anti-vac sentiment is declining um
it's not as low as we would like the
latest monmouth poll
says 20 of americans don't want to get
the vaccine
if they can avoid it which i guess means
if they need to get it for their job
some of them would one out of five that
actually
is enough to get us to hurt immunity but
that's only from adults and adults don't
include kids
so if we get to 80 of the total
population we will actually be good and
we'll look into this in more detail
tomorrow the anti-vaxx
sentiment being led by republicans
43 percent of republicans
say they do not want the coronavirus
vaccine so we'll dig into those numbers
tomorrow but the latest cdc data on
covet and vaccinated people
extremely extremely reassuring data that
is really the takeaway
matt gates it's almost like every day
there's a new
scandal facing beleaguered republican
congressman
matt gates earlier this week we told you
about
his apparent involvement in running a
shill candidate in florida's ninth
district i won't retell the entire story
but you can check it out
on our youtube channel or the podcast
from earlier this week i think it was
monday or tuesday where we covered that
um
we also know that he is being uh looked
at for involvement in child sex
trafficking and a whole bunch of other
things the fbi or federal authorities
rather
seized his iphone some time ago it's
looking really really bad for matt gates
republican congressman steve scalise who
is a horrible person
says that if indeed
matt gates is charged if there are
charges levied against him that
they would take action and remove him
from his committee
assignments if the department of justice
files
charges according to newsweek scalise
added that historically lawmakers who
face charges
have been removed from committee
assignments immediately as a precedent
this is the same this mirrors the house
republican rules
that lawmakers indicted for felonies and
sentenced to at least two years in
prison must resign now the weird thing
about sentenced to two years in prison
is
their terms are only two years long so
that
it sort of seems a little strange that
you you have to resign
from committees uh but i guess you could
be sentenced and get a suspended
sentence or something like that i don't
know
scalise going on to say it's hard to
speculate on rumors but if something
really formal happened from justice we
would of course react and take action
scalise says he has not spoken with matt
gates
and has not heard matt gates explanation
for the allegations
but imagines he will be speaking with
him this week
saying quote it's serious things alleged
obviously we will want to get the facts
gates continues to deny the allegations
although the denials often also include
raising the alarm with additional
derogatory information for example
when he first went on tucker carlson's
show
to deny some element of the allegations
he also said i've never paid anyone for
sex which at the time
was not even part of what we thought was
going on increasingly it seems matt
gates actually has paid people for sex
and whatever your thoughts are
about paying people for sex the
boneheadedness
of matt gates raising new issues that
weren't even
yet being looked at it's odd to say the
least
gates did not go to a weekly meeting of
house republicans
yesterday according to steve scalise and
it seems as though increasingly many
republicans i mean like it seems like
marjorie taylor green
is sort of sticking with them she may go
down with the ship um
it seems as though you know some of the
wackier members
are sticking with matt gates but
increasingly lots of people are
are abandoning him it may indeed be a
ship that simply goes down now as far as
judiciary
there's a kind of weird i don't know if
i'd call it
i guess it is a conflict of interest
because matt gates is currently on
the judiciary committee the house
judiciary committee
has oversight power over the very
department of justice
that would be indicting matt gates it's
not
as though there's a very clear way in
which he's going to be able to do
x or y as it relates to the
investigation against him
but steve scalise saying well he'll have
to resign from the committees if there
are charges
and one of the committees he's on does
oversight of the entity that would be
charging him
that's you know that that's certainly a
question mark
and then lastly you know steve scalise
as i mentioned is a horrible person
he really can't be trusted so there's a
question of whether they will
actually do it it's clearly in the house
rules
scalise is saying republicans would
demand that he do it
um i wouldn't be shocked if gates does
get
charged and the house controlled by
democrats based on the rules moves
forward
with stripping gates of his committee
assignments i wouldn't be shocked if
some republicans pulled out the
allegations alone or not evidence and
this isn't what should happen even
though these are the house rules
we'll wait and see i'm increasingly of
the mindset that there's probably some
kind of charge coming against matt gates
but uh without a doubt he is innocent
until proven guilty and he has not yet
even been charged so we have to allow
the investigations to be carried out i
have a voicemail number that number is
2192davidp
i asked on the show yesterday if you are
a non-right winger
and you have a my pillow pillow please
let me know like
the pillow can't possibly be that good
right it seems to me that if you buy a
my pillow pillow
it's political i got a couple of
voicemails about it take a listen to
this first one
hey my pillows is a good pillow period
no matter what he thinks and also it's
pretty slicky you put an
advertisement on this at the end of the
thing right pretty sick of you
kind of thing but my pillows is a good
pillow
period this is how we're calling from
the great state of texas
all right so howard from texas likes the
pilla uh here's one other one who says i
have a pillow it's actually not that
great
hi david this is jack from new jersey
and recently on your show you put out a
call to uh
members of your audience yes who are on
the left who
own a my pillow and let me tell you i'm
as left as they come and i
don't own just one my pillow but i own
two my pillows yeah uh i'm here
live in my bed right now with both my
pillows uh giving them a test run
and if i may say they're they're just
pillows
uh i don't remember when i got that i
don't even
remember where i got them but i have
them uh
they're not as good as the tempurpedic
pillows i have they're kind of a base
pillow okay i wouldn't recommend
they're just a toil thanks dude just a
pillow just a pillow
not exactly a ringing endorsement all
right so that there is
i'm actually surprised that the number
of people in the audience that have
these pillows
we have a great bonus show for you today
kim potter
the officer who killed dante wright has
been
charged with second degree manslaughter
okay we will talk about that on today's
bonus show democrats are now pushing
for republican support on asian american
hate crimes
legislation will they get it unclear
and the biden administration is pushing
for a major
expansion of offshore wind energy
you are starting to see republicans say
oh but it doesn't look
good to look offshore off of our
beautiful
beaches and water you know into the into
the waterways and seeing
um wind turbines that is now what they
are saying
so we will talk about that this is a
great push it would be great to expand
that
all of those stories and more and i will
be joined by producer pat
on today's bonus show get instant access
by signing up at joinpacman.com i'll see
you then